I think also our ego like I remind like
my ego I'm like I can do this I can
handle so much Kelly Clarkson getting
real about her marriage to X Brandon
Blackstock I am an open book but I I
don't do it for anyone else honestly
while chatting with Glennon Doyle on the
week and do hard things podcast Monday
the singer opens up about ending their
relationship in 2020 and what kept her
from leaving for so long my ego is like
I can
I can control my actions I can control
my reactions I can I can do this and I
can reach this person and I can get
through and I can and it becomes a
little bit of your ego it gets in the
way life just kind of happens and it
takes turns that you don't expect as a
child of divorce Kelly says she didn't
want the same thing to happen to their
children seven-year-old son Remington an
eight-year-old daughter River if I'm
being completely honest
we don't want to do what we saw done you
know I'm saying like I'm like ugh I
don't want my kids to be those kids at
school it's a little different they grew
up here it's a very Progressive City and
even New York that's Progressive and but
in the South there were like two of us
with divorced parents in our class so it
was very different this isn't the first
time the Stars let fans in on her life I
was destroyed like on the ground like
crying you know it's just divorce is a
really
thing last March kelly didn't hold back
when she made an appearance on another
podcast Andrew Martinez IRL I think the
thing about divorce that you know
especially having it publicized like
it's just you know it and people
thinking they know the whole thing the
hardest part of that is like it wasn't
an overnight decision I'm not the person
to be like oh well you know oh it never
had or nothing like that no it was
beautiful for a minute you know I'm
saying it was awesome for a minute and
then and that's okay it just didn't work
out also sharing how she took an open
and honest approach when it came to
talking about the split with their kids
but a lot of times it would be like you
know I'm just really sad you know I wish
Mommy and Daddy were in the same house I
wish and they're really honest about it
and that's and I'm raising that kind of
individual I want you to be honest with
me and I just sit there and I'm like I
get it I'm from a divorced family as
well I get it that's that sucks you know
but we're gonna work it out and you are
so loved by both of us I am an open book
but at some point I'm a mama bear more
than I am a person in the public eye so
I care 100 more about my children than I
do anything else on this planet
[Music]
foreign